[Music]
Hey
looking good what is the best the
world-famous Marwin Marx art
installation so that's a guy yeah right
up there some Nazi thugs jumped him it's
a miracle he survived I was a hell of a
good artist and now I can barely write
my name so my dolls have to tell the
story
at your service members all
I just moved in across the street if not
all the details who are they they're
Nazis torturing Oggy why because he's
different
the women of Marwan protect me you are
safe but toast just for you there are
the dogs people you know yeah everyone
has a place here in Marwan I just moved
in across this gene so are you gonna go
to the sentencing no suffering human
being I want these guys to get more than
just a slap on the wrist it's important
that you're there to look you're a
sandwich straight in the eye I'm not
really sure how to do this
are you gonna man up and put an end to
this crap what are you talking about
we're one in the same pal if I can be a
hero so can you maybe the dolls should
stay in the car I never go anywhere
without my back
apparently you gotta embrace their pain
it's the only way Marc skinny he'll I
got your back okay
bottoms up girls
but I heard you yelling for more gumbo
no no gumbo love opinion
hey is our rocket fuel
I have my art and I have my friends I
have hope
don't be okay hey oh yeah that's kind of
violent but at least the Nazis are dead
you